trappes en région parisienne un
professeur de philosophie sous
protection policière enseignant depuis
20 ans didier lemaire a l'air depuis des
années de la progression d'une emprise
communautaire toujours plus forte sur
les consciences comme sur les corses
sont ses mots il avait même écrit au
président de la république aujourd'hui
c'est donc entouré de policiers qu'il se
rend à l'école je suis sous escorte
depuis le mois de novembre
chaque fois que je monte en voiture je
vérifie que les portes sont bien fermées
que je ne suis pas suivi je ne veux pas
vivre dans la peur je n'attend plus
qu'une chose son exfiltration et écouter
ses réactions d'élèves du lycée la
plaine de nom le feu à trappes
l'indicé dit sensible contredit mme joya
de l'apprentissage comme tout quoi après
de dire comme quoi les gens prêtent rap
c'est une perdue ou je sais pas quoi
c'est son opinion en est là c'est ce qui
pour autant de recevoir des menaces de
mort et plus car il n'a pas du tout pas
du coup la menace de mort qui est
impardonnable c'est pas normal
normalement bien normal en cours pour
faire court normalement il doit aimer
son métier tout ça et là ils le font
détester et brana quoi je trouve ça
dommage pas avoir peur puisque du coup à
cause du professeur à ça mais elle pâtit
qui est décédé il peut avoir peur que ça
lui arrive aussi de se faire agresser de
cette manière c'est triste parce que
monsieur le maire c'est un bon prof il
est gentil qu'on menace comme ça c'est
bête